[Musique]
c'est un message fort que la république
envoie en créant un délit autonome
visant à sanctionner des thérapies
conversion
fisac ne sont plus acceptables peu
importe pour l'orientation sexuelle ou
son identité de genre
chacun a le droit à la protection de la
république et accepter l'autre au delà
de ces différences c'est aussi
contribuer à faire de notre société un
espace de liberté
g
m
une
ce texte est nécessaire alors que ces
thérapies de conversion principalement
des adolescents de jeunes a dû à une
période de leur vie thème de
questionnements de doutes une période de
leur vie où ils sont bien souvent
vulnérables la république se doit de les
protéger nous leur devons la possibilité
de s'épanouir librement et de se
construire et à tous ceux qui ont été
victimes à tous ceux qui ont eu le
courage de témoigner comme aux anonymes
nous reconnaissons leur thème et nous
sommes aujourd'hui tellement à leur côté